[Music]
there's been a real psychological sea
change across generations in Asia older
Asians if you take for example Japanese
or Koreans or even Chinese they grew up
in a world in which there was the Cold
War but the United States prevailed it
was the world's sole superpower and of
course for Japan and South Korea there
was an alliance system in which they
were part of the u.s. security system
that really governed and provided the
stability for East Asia so they look up
to the United States in many ways but a
younger generation didn't grow up with
that experience of the Cold War and they
didn't grow up with that sort of
American even post Cold War triumphalism
because the majority of Asian peoples or
younger populations were of course born
after 1990 and in many Asian countries
that represents the majority of entire
countries population so their memories
when they think of America are of the
9/11 terrorist attacks the financial
crisis the election of Donald Trump and
so forth so their views are really quite
quite different about America they don't
remember America firsthand from what it
was they only remember what they see
they see a lot of political division
they see a sort of social fragmentation
and they see that their economies
particularly that of China are actually
as large as that of America and they see
how innovative they themselves have
become so in depending on the country
that you're looking at in Asia you're
seeing less and less Asians actually
traveling to the US at all or traveling
to Europe it's also because the West is
trying so hard to bring its best foot
forward its educational system to Asia
so in Singapore you have campuses of MIT
and Yale Georgetown and Duke and other
universities have campuses in China and
so forth so Asians now have the luxury
of enjoying a high quality Western
education without ever having to leave
home so this is another reason why you
see this Asian first I like to say an
Asia first mentality where they believe
that they really are the center of the
world and everyone is bringing their
best ex
sports to them it's very commonly
thought today that we live in a world
where walls and borders are going up
where protectionism and xenophobia and
populism or the order of the day where
anti-globalization movements are
sweeping our politics and our society
but if you look at Asia which is again
the majority of the world population you
don't really see those sentiments you
have a pro globalization sentiment
that's very strong because they know
that it is globalization that has
elevated them economically you also have
a lot more demographic openness it's to
a remarkable extent because these
civilizations of Asia are quite mutually
unintelligible they're very diverse
Indian people don't have much in common
with Chinese people they can't even
understand each other and yet what
you're seeing happening just on the
basis of demographic supply and demand
is that the aging countries of Asia like
Japan South Korea and China itself are
importing people from around Asia like
never before
the younger vibrant working populations
of the Philippines and Indonesia all the
way to Pakistan are sending people to
the aging societies as caregivers and
also to study in their better
universities so if you look at a country
like Japan which we think of as being
almost self isolating and homogeneous
they've actually never been as many
foreigners living in Japan as you have
today and in South Korea you have a
rising rate of intermarriage with Korean
and Chinese populations so Asia to the
extent that one can describe it as a
melting pot is becoming more and more so
now as a percentage of the Chinese
population foreigners will always be a
drop in the bucket but the overall trend
is towards a greater mingling of Asian
peoples especially in the places that
they where they meet in the middle the
cities the thriving metropolitan
cosmopolitan cities like Hong Kong and
Singapore for example which have very
high percentage of their populations
being foreign-born on top of all of this
because of the high growth rates there's
a huge desire among Western populations
Europeans and Americans to go and to
experiment in Asia
the entrepreneurs in Asia to build
businesses in Asia to serve the markets
of Asia and that means that countries
are opening up to that talent as well so
you see developing countries like
Thailand or others having entrepreneur
visa schemes or investor visa schemes
where you can pretty much have a
residence visa on arrival and come and
stay for four or five years build your
business there explore the market invest
in the population train local people and
if you do that and if you make a good
profit you'll be allowed to stay even
longer so what we're seeing is that the
tenure of an expat who moves to Asia is
getting longer and longer
in this book I talked about the rise of
what I call American Asians now I grew
up as an Asian American I emigrated to
the United States and my family and most
immigrants like me never thought we
would ever leave America there's been a
pattern of the last 5060 years or more
where people want to move from south to
north and east to west but now suddenly
what I've noticed is that you have a lot
of Americans and Europeans moving east
on one-way tickets and I'm one of them
because I relocated to Singapore about
five years ago and suddenly we find
ourselves in a situation where it sort
of just become home in a default way and
we'll be there indefinitely and the same
certainly applies to the young
entrepreneurs that I'm seeing arriving
in Asia now the first thing you'll
notice when you do arrive is that you're
not the only one as I just mentioned
there's already thousands and thousands
and in the aggregate perhaps a couple of
million young Western citizens who have
already migrated to Asia and you'll find
that they already have paved the way for
you you'll find their co-working spaces
and their social clubs and their
hangouts and their meetups thriving and
it's not just in the wealthy cities like
Tokyo or Hong Kong or Taipei or
Singapore but now the second-tier cities
have been really become really hot tech
hubs and entrepreneurial hubs because of
the market size a country like Indonesia
and a city like Jakarta is not
considered the most livable city in the
world but it's certainly very affordable
and given the market size of more than
200 million people it's a hotbed of
entrepreneurial ism and activity the
same is true of a place like Bangkok or
Ho Chi Minh City it really is a thriving
ecosystem if you will and it's not just
one city in one country it's all of them
networking more and more together so we
tend to think of innovation and
entrepreneurial ISM having a physical or
geographic locus a place like Silicon
Valley but what's happening in Asia is
because the money is in one place the
academic talent is another place and the
market is in a third place and the
software developers in a fourth place
they're all really working together
across borders and that's helping to
build this Greater Asian ecosystem so
that means therefore that when you go to
Asia don't be so sure where you're going
to live quote-unquote because you may
live in a whole bunch of places over the
period of time that you're there
[Music]